well you know I've spoken all over the
place and I'm a storyteller but the
problem is that I can go on for hours
and hours and hours and my you know with
just one story
so actually I'm going to use these
visuals so that I can get everything in
that I want to in the time that I have I
hope that's okay with you if it's not
it's okay
anyway I'm gonna do it when I was 15
years old I wrote this poem about the
school I was going to I hate this darn
unthinking school which professes to
teach you the golden rule you fool me
and I'll make you a fool against this I
will repel many's the time when I've
hated to stay when the board boring
teacher had nothing to say but no says
the teacher you can't go away and this I
will also retell so I learned what the
board boring teacher had taught and
thusly I learned to be bored on the spot
and ever since I've been bored at the
thought of the trash that the school has
to sell oh I'm sure education in schools
not all bad and I'll know things of
interest when I am a grad but the
camouflaged job on the interest is sad
and the learning won't set very well and
so every morning at just 8 o'clock I
rush into the school and behind me they
lock the door to my prison and I start
to walk through the prison from cell to
cell
so you can see I already had a bad
attitude when I was 15
oh it had about it I think I know what
that attitude came from when I was very
young our family would visit my mother's
parents in Boston every week or two my
grandfather William Blatt was a lawyer
and occasional judge he had been
president of the Massachusetts law
Society but his real passion was writing
and philosophy when we visited him my
grandfather would sit down with me and
asked me what I wanted to learn that
simple act was the most powerful
influence of my idea of how learning
should take place people probably
thought he was crazy talking to a
seven-year-old about atheism agnosticism
about what makes things humorous the ego
the iddah and the super-ego the causes
of the world wars Einstein's theory
great discoveries in science anything I
wanted to know but I remember these
things to this day it seemed perfectly
sensible to ask me what I was interested
in what I wanted to learn my grandfather
also wrote epigrams little sayings that
appeared every day over the headlines of
the Boston Post in fact to honor him we
recently published a book of his
epigrams with cartoons made by Albert
lamb here are a couple of them one we
get so used to slavery that we regard
our manacles as ornaments two if you
always do as you're told you will always
be told what to do and they're still
relevant after 60 years not long after
that I wrote after I wrote that poem I
organized some of my friends into a
group we called the thinkers club very
modestly we met at each other's houses
there were all the elite students of the
school except for me they went to
Harvard Yale and Princeton we got
together about twice a week and our
agenda was to brainstorm any questions
we wanted to discuss without censorship
there were no adults involved if we
didn't know the answers we went out and
found deaf speakers or went to see
rabbis ministers and philosophy students
I now realize that that was the first
school that I started
a comedian on Saturday Night Live told
the story about a university dean who
said you know at our college we teach
one year of language in one day we teach
one year of language in one day when
asked how they could do that he said
well you know when you take a language
in school and a year later you only
remember four words we teach those four
words of course we laugh because we
assume that people don't remember what
they learned in school we also assume
that children hate school but why do we
accept this modern brain research shows
very clearly that children are natural
learners the brain wants to learn I
think people's negative experiences
carry over to their jobs for the rest of
their lives
I think people accept jobs they hate
because they're used to schools they
hate in my experience graduates have
learner-centered and democratic schools
usually find jobs they like to do right
if your child says he or she hates
school listen to that that means
something's wrong with their school and
you need to get your child out of it and
find an alternative an alternative
school is one which is based on the
interest of the learner and empowers
them to make decisions about their own
education we were involved with learner
centered up centered approaches believe
that children are natural learners in
fact when you force children to learn
things that they aren't interested in it
tends to extinguish that natural ability
to learn the human spirit is very strong
so students may resist that
extinguishing for many years but after
five or six years the first paradigm
becomes self-fulfilling and kids appear
to become lazy and not interested in
learning for its own sake that interest
can sometimes be rekindled in the right
environment but in democratic schools we
often observe a period of detoxification
that takes place and students
coming from traditional schools
detoxification is a period of expression
of anger and having been forced to learn
things they weren't interested in
generally the longer they were in a
coercive environment the longer it takes
to recover the natural ability to learn
but after that that can be an explosion
of self-motivated learning how fast can
a student learn a lesson been forced to
learn we once had an intern who had been
unschooled he was always able to follow
his own interest at sixteen he decided
to go to college but in order to get
into the college he chose one of the
tests he had to pass was algebra and
he'd never been interested in algebra
had never studied it so he decided to
study algebra on his own for one week
then aced the test he even taught others
so now we have a ratio what is supposed
to take a year took a week a 52 to 1
ratio for a non schooler nice ratio huh
so if students are able to have the
freedom to follow their own interests
what happens when you have a whole group
or a whole school of them this is where
democratic process comes in the
democratic meeting ensures that the
freedom and rights of the individual do
not encroach upon the rights of others
in the group and it goes beyond that the
interactive process usually comes up
with better solutions than any one
individual could it is a
learner-centered process for a group the
word democracy is one of the most
overused words these days which tends to
water down its meaning but democracy in
this case means something very specific
to people in democratic schools the
empowerment of a group of people to make
real decisions in their meetings and
whatever it is decided in that meeting
actually happens I think that the best
way to prepare students to participate
in a democratic society is to have them
grow up in democratic school
why do we why do we have them experience
12 years of a dictatorship and then
expect them to be ready for democracy
we've developed a form of democratic
process that we learned from the mohawks
of the Iroquois Confederacy the Iroquois
Confederacy was the model that Jefferson
and Franklin used when they created the
plan for democratic decision-making for
the United colonies of North America
well that's what they called our
respective country at first I actually
saw a Franklin's letter in the archives
in Washington at that time the only
other models around were kings and
queens monarchy back in the late 1960s I
visited the Mohawk tribe in upstate New
York and learned how the Iroquois made
decisions for their Confederacy and
their approach the minority was honored
and allowed to say why they voted
against the majority if they wished they
or others could then ask for more
discussion with new and hopefully better
proposals if nobody asked for a revote
the community was saying that the final
proposal was acceptable we developed a
process of on that approach which I've
demonstrated in many places around the
country and around the world when I go
into a democratic meeting I'm fully
prepared to advocate from my point of
view but I'm also confident that the
power of the meeting the combining of
all those free wills will come up with
something better something we all never
thought of it takes a little longer than
pure democracy but the decisions seem to
be made more effectively and with more
authorities I sometimes heard of this
approach called unstructured but a true
democracy has a very complex structure
sometimes I compare it to Penn Station
at rush hour it looks like chaos to
those who don't understand it but
actually every single person has a place
to start from and the place they expect
to get to in the democratic school
virtually everyone knows about all that
decisions that have been made now that's
pretty structured and disciplined I
think the power of the democratic
meeting is something to behold let me
give you an example of a demonstration I
did for a small school in Virginia in
the meeting the girls complained that
they wanted a girls room rather than a
unisex bathroom that was voted on and
passed but one person voted against it
when asked why he pointed out that the
school would be moving in three weeks so
be a waste of money and could be applied
to the new building of course in the
revote it wasn't passed when this
happens in my demonstrations it is very
important because people realize that
decisions are not for ordained or made
in stone with democratic process the
participants learn how to listen to
every voice when we were organizing
Brooklyn free school we would have
meetings in people's apartments every
two weeks we encouraged people to bring
their children but they would run off
the kids would play amongst themselves
at one meeting people have brought three
six-year-olds I told the group that I
was sure these children had opinions
about what the proposed school should be
like so they were asked to come into the
meeting when they realized that we knew
that they had opinions one six-year-old
said it's very important that the school
not be too clean or have no furniture if
it did we wouldn't be able to run around
and jump and have fun people would worry
too much about the furniture of course
it was right but who else but a
six-year-old would have thought of this
I learned something new every time I'm
asked to demonstrate democratic process
I'll give you a few examples in India I
was asked to help demonstrate who asked
to help democratize a school with 2,500
students in it
nobody in the United States has ever
asked me to do that eventually we
established a system in which each class
would ever representative lead a meeting
in their classroom and votes on the
issues on the agenda would be taken and
votes tallied those representatives
would bring the votes with them to be
told in the Parliament so it wasn't a
representative system in this usual
sense and all the students could have
the experience of speaking in a
relatively small group situation not
lying along after that I was asked to
demonstrate democratic process in a
school we had helped to start in our
school start of course the oldest
student was five years old even though
I've done this many times I'm always
shocked at the power of the results
because I did not grow up in such a
system so as I drove over I had serious
doubts about whether this would work I
was thinking that at least I would have
to make the agenda for them and as I
walked in i heard a two-year-old
screaming mom oh I was thinking well
when they gathered around the table I
told them that at a meeting we could
talk about good ideas for the school or
problems in the school immediately most
of the hands went up we had our agenda
about such subjects as not going outside
if you had a cold and it was cold out
and not eating chocolate in the
afternoon because it had a caffeine like
substance in it that was brought up by a
four year old my organization the
alternative education resource
organization has helped start more than
50 new educational alternatives in the
last few years probably the biggest
revolution that could take place in
schools all across the country would be
to simply have the classroom door open
and have a worthwhile place for the kids
to go if they don't want to be in the
class this is already the case in the
school of self-determination an
inner-city public school with 600
students
in this school the students have a
constitutional right to leave any class
they want without explanation the
decisions in the school are made by a
democratic Parliament the kids also
interview the teachers before they're
hired the teachers get to do a practice
class and the students vote on which
teachers are going to be hired oh and
where's this school in inner-city Moscow
Russia
my mission is from is to promote the
education revolution to make
learner-centered empowering education
available to students everywhere I will
help anyone who wants to change the
system from within but personally I
think we're more likely to change it by
creating good models outside the system
democratic process is not hard to do let
me show you what I mean who here in the
audience has some ideas or proposals on
how to make education really learner
centered and empowering to students who
has some ideas okay let's have you just
come up to the stage just for a minute
quickly quickly people who have ideas
come on up Oh guys make a circle make a
circle
okay
you're late oh this is how it starts
thank you
you